for my next few videos it's going to
take somewhat of a diversion path from
the political matters that you've become
accustomed to from this channel into a
foray back to my roots as a theoretical
physicist I'm still gonna talk about
philosophical issues such as the
existence of God consciousness and free
will my inaugural guest is the great
Professor Brian Keating
someone who I admire to such a degree
that I was timorous and forgot familiar
terms how to pronounce them such as
homogeneity and isotropy you'll see what
I mean he has a YouTube channel that I
think you should subscribe to it's one
that I personally covet
he's handle such heavy hitter notables
as Eric Weinstein Jim Simons Stephen
Wolfram enjoy no problem alright I'm
here with Professor Brian Keating the
magnanimous and beatific Bryan Keating
you should check out his youtube channel
because he interviews plenty of
physicists as well as people who are
watching this may be familiar with what
Dave Rubin some other guests which I'm
not sure why you're interviewing them
we're gonna get to that which is for
example beyond meet people okay first of
all let's get through the questions one
by one what are your goals explain to
the audience what you do with your
channel what your goals are as you as a
professor for your life yeah so my basic
dictum in life is that it's incredibly
short and you have to make the most of
it and you have to do everything you can
until we invent time travel we have to
do everything we can in order to make
each moment as meaningful as invested in
with meaning as possible and so I do
that in in different ways different
habits rituals practices but one thing
I've always wanted to do is to write a
book and leave a legacy as a as an
author and I've learned so much from
other authors that I wanted to start
something especially during this time of
kovat to give back to people that have
been my silent mentors or did
student learning mentors namely folks
like as you mentioned Michael Shermer
has been on my podcast we've had people
like we David Kaiser very famous and
well-known physicist all the way down to
people that have influenced my life
personally that haven't written books
such as Jim Simon's who he had on the
podcast for Father's Day and again
following Carl Sagan's dictum that books
are magic books are proof that human
beings can work magic you have an
author's voice possibly a long-dead
author from communicating from hundreds
or maybe thousands of years ago in the
case of you know I read a lot of the
Bible and things like that we can get
into and how it influences me is you get
to create the sort of artificial I call
artificial wisdom we hear a lot I'm sure
you've had a lot of contact with people
that study artificial intelligence what
I'm more interested in is artificial
wisdom namely how can you accrue wisdom
without going through all the
experiences that other brilliant people
have gone through so I love to read
books I love to write books I'm thinking
about my second book now as we speak and
putting it together based on a lot of
the interviews and things that have
emerged from the conversations with
these luminaries that I'm really
fortunate to talk to him are you
defining wisdom nationalism so
artificial wisdom is just kind of a play
off on artificial intelligence namely
that that you have an awful lot of
knowledge that's available to humanity
through things Wikipedia the internet
etc but and in fact I remind people that
the word science in Latin means
knowledge doesn't mean wisdom wisdom is
the ability to synthesize fat pieces of
knowledge in a way that we don't know
but maybe uniquely human
and I think synthesizing it to avoid we
I'm also a private pilot if like tiny
little planes and one of the things we
say is you have to learn from the
mistakes of others because you won't
live long enough to make them all
yourself
so that's sort of the you know kind of
the 10,000 hour rule applied to pilots
which i think is one of malcolm
gladwell's
examples of you know truly outstanding
pilots are those that have obtained
10,000 hours
and you can only get that far if you've
done things and benefited from others
wisdom the situations that they've been
in so that you don't have to go through
it so it's not just about knowledge I
mean I think Derek Siver's once said you
know if if it was all about knowledge
we'd all be billionaires with six pack
apps there's an abundance of knowledge
wisdom is synthesizing it distilling it
and catalyzing the many disparate pieces
that you get into some coherent form of
of life message or with our vision which
is what I try to maintain have you heard
of John for Mickey no Hammond who's that
curry cognitive scientist from U of T
okay well there's two interviews with
him on my channel Oh extensively studies
wisdom from a cognitive science
perspective oh wow yeah yeah okay maybe
we'll get and tell you how they get in
touch with him now you mentioned that
the mind might not be what the human
mind might be uniquely predisposed or
capable of wisdom that is that is doing
of so much knowledge down to something
that's practical which implies a goal
and then we can talk about what where do
you get those goals from later and we
get to the biblical section do you
happen to do you think that the mind can
be mechanized that is what I mean is
that a machine can simulate the mind
yeah so I've had some conversations with
people about this and actually the most
interesting people I've talked to our
people in the realm of music in the arts
I interviewed controversial but
interesting very interesting person
named zoobi he's a musician in the UK
that he does a lot of rap and improv
based rap music he's also very
knowledgeable about jazz and cetera and
I also interviewed a very one of my best
friends Stephon Alexander who's a
professional jazz musician but also
professor of theoretical physics at
Brown University where I went to grad
school and these two gentlemen have the
idea that music can be synthesized and
it can be made by computers but there's
something uniquely almost almost endemic
to human beings that allows for sort of
what Stephan calls this path integral
approach where the
mind is exploring and seeking out ways
to minimize a quantity we physicists
call action and he's doing it doing it
in a way that a computer can solve you
know theoretically can reduce what's
called the Lagrangian or solve this
action principle of the integral of
Lagrangian but but it may not be able to
create that idea you know the the notion
of an artificial physicist that max
tegmark was also a friend and colleague
has proposed you know the ability to
replicate the laws of physics merely
based on computing power seems dubious
to me I'm not saying it's impossible but
these metrics that we have are often
superimposed upon biases that the
individuals who program the artificial
intelligence is the machine learning
algorithms unconsciously or sometimes
consciously bestow upon that so the
Turing test you know is the classic
definition it turns out you know Turing
Turing almost inadvertently came up with
it or he he wasn't necessarily thinking
about it the way that we think about it
now but he was so prescient that he
really pre saged the fact that yeah this
question of whether or not a computer
and artificial intelligent intelligence
could mimic a human being is is
certainly a very very interesting topic
to me and I've actually talked about it
recently with who did I talk about this
week I think it was James Altucher who's
like a pundit blogger prolific podcast
or author and and he was saying things
like the Turing test you could think
about it being passed right now like
sometimes I'm I give I give my my iPad
to my to my I have young kids I'll give
an iPad to them I'll play with it and
then they'll come back to me and later
on they're like swipe my face like
they're trying to change the page of my
face you know unfortunately for them it
doesn't change the way I look but but it
made me think like could you could the
Turing test be kind of age dependent
could you could could the Turing test be
passed already for very highly
intelligent animals like like bonobos or
what have you
in other words that you could actually
pass it already or young children so a
young child wouldn't know if it's their
dad talking to them or in artificial
intelligence so those are very
fascinating questions I don't know
however again what
is the impact cuz I don't know not an
expert in this field but what is the
uniquely human aspect of intelligence
that proves so resistant to perfect
mimicry and ie the Turing test I just
not something I personally you know
investigated very deeply but I think it
is a very important question
hmm I was reading recently mine machines
and girdle my Lucas have you heard of
that paper I've heard of it yes I'm
ready he says that a mind that a machine
can simulate any aspect of the mind but
not every aspect and that seems like a
contradiction but you can also think of
it like a machine can simulate any
natural number but not every natural
number right and it can do things better
than human beings right I mean know one
of the you know what one of the best
uses of a quantum computer is that a
classical computer can't model right
that's a quantum computer in other words
a quantum computer is the ideal device
if you will technology to model quantum
processes lagrangians hamiltonians the
question is as you say you know because
it surpasses any human being or any
conventional silicon computer or
whatever classical computer does that
mean it could do so in every field it's
it's hard to say yes I guess that paper
you're saying argues no yeah and it says
we need to make a delineation between
superiority and equivalence so a
computer can be much better than us and
it is in various aspects but it doesn't
mean it's equivalent he gives an
in-principle argument for why can't be
using girdle what if it's a formal
system that's consistent and sound then
it can there are statements that he
can't prove to be true but we can see
when we stand outside the system that
it's true and just based on that alone
there's a difference between our minds
and machines have you studied much of
girdles incompleteness theorem I I
wouldn't say I've studied it I've
familiarized myself with it in the
following sense that I believe that that
physicists have a deep envy of girdles
incompleteness theorem for the following
reason it's very hard to find statements
about physics itself that come from
within physics itself in other words
it's very hard to say
what constitutes physics what
constitutes scientific methods some as
in your fellow Torontonian are I guess
he's in Waterloo but Lee Smolin who's a
very good friend of mine he'll be on the
podcast soon he and I have traveled
about this he actually doesn't even
believe that the scientific method is is
as resilient you know as a truly
definable conjecture in other words he
argues you know with the kind of Carl
Sagan or Neil deGrasse Tyson you know
simple statement of what the scientific
method is he argues based on a book that
I can provide for you guys later but
there's arguments against the existence
of even the scientific method so now
once you have this and you try to equate
it and you try to ask like am I wasting
my life like I'm building this huge
Observatory with 300 of my most
brilliant colleagues in the world is it
just a waste because ultimately it's
tantamount to astrology now I think I
can make very strong arguments that it's
not however as we will get to certainly
there are aspects of this of this
pursuit of studying the early universe
that some claim are tantamount to
astrology or tantamount to you know
phrenology or something like this that
we are doing what's that how small so we
can get into that one with regard to
string theory the multiverse I saw you
want to talk about that we should
definitely get into that but just
finishing up on because you asked me
about girdle so what's important about
girdle is that it shows you the
limitations of the mathematical the
mathematical construct that human beings
have invented and discovered now I say
that because Jim Simons and I had a
wonderful conversation I asked him is
mathematics invented or discovered and
he said it's both because their only way
to find out
what is new is to discover something and
when you discover something new like the
chern-simons relations and differential
forms etcetera when you do that you
learn new things and you in some sense
invent new technology literally I mean
there are people that say that
effectively turn Symonds can be used to
derive the Einstein field equations so
you know did Einstein you know discover
that or do you know it did he invent it
he used tools in mathematics that had
never been used in physics so getting
back to curdle I think that physicists
would love to have a similar statement
even
though some mathematicians my friend
Janna Levin who was on the my podcast I
haven't released her episode but she
wrote a great book called the madman
dreams of Turing machines
it's about girdle and Turing and this
fictitious relationship between the two
of them in Vienna she meant it said it's
a fictional book yeah so she's she's an
amazing writer she's written
best-selling non-fiction books about
LIGO and about
physicists as well she's yeah she's a
chair named chair professor at Barnard
College at Columbia University yeah
she's amazing I would love to connect
you with her but she she writes fiction
and this book is this is fictional kind
of character of how they both you know
we're led to basically take their own
lives and and what happened how they did
so one did so via ingesting a poisoned
Apple and one did so by starving himself
to death and and just just the amazing
connections as she draws it's been
called like Maria Popova it's her one of
her favorite books of all time and she's
you know one of the most brilliant
people anyway getting back to girdles so
I would say I wish that there was and I
think many physicists wish that there
was something besides popper no popper
we can get into demarcation conjectures
effectively we don't have a hard and
fast mathematically consistent rule at
least within the realm of
self-consistency that girdled delineates
we don't have something that tells me
cosmology or you know a condensed matter
physics is a waste of time because it's
it's it's logically as equivalent to or
not to some other branch of you know
what we can consider metaphysics or non
physics like astrology so is cosmology
like astrology we don't have as cleanly
divided demarcations between those
despite what most people think coming
from popper now as I said you're an
experimentalist the audience might not
know that well we'll know from the
introduction yeah which is different
than most of the people that I talk to I
talk to theoretical physicists yeah and
and that puts you in a unique
perspective many theoretical physicists
including Penrose and Fineman I mean
Dyson believe that that girdles
incompleteness theorem has something to
say about our ability to come up
with the theory of everything if there
examine the existence of one as well so
whether or not we can find it and
whether or not existed or two different
topics well what do you see as an
experimentalist girdle's incompleteness
theorems implications for physics itself
yeah so you know I've had on Penrose a
hat on Dyson many times and Penrose many
times martin rees and i have had
wonderful conversations as well I would
say that exactly as you know and you
know you're the first person ever
noticed this I don't know if you use
like metrics with your podcast Kurt like
I always like if I ask somebody a
question they say I've never thought of
that before or I've never been asked
that before or they sit there like this
that's a sign of a good podcast okay so
I want to give you that little metric
that little love what do they call that
KPI key performance good job there so so
almost no one has ever asked me about
the unique perspective that an
experimentalist has on this and I think
it's it's a it's a little unfortunate
because most many people see the
theoretical physicist the Brian Greene's
the Janna Levin M on Alexander's Jim
Gates Lee Smolin they see the those are
physicist Michio Kaku they see those or
the physicist and the you know and the
Brian Keating's don't get the attention
up I'm clamoring for attention to Brian
green but the bottom line is they can
work and I had this conversation with
Eric Weinstein yesterday just the two of
us you know hanging out and chatting on
the phone
and I was like look you know an
experimentalist I can point to the key
performance indicators that I achieved
every day I keep a journal I have I have
you know metrics for what I want to
succeed in each day today's list I could
show it to you in my diary across the
room yeah I talked to Kurt and and you
know communicate new ideas so so I keep
that now a theorist might have one or
two papers in his or her career that and
that's their entire career
now so some experimentalist might not
even have you know more than that in
terms of one experiment my so my
experiments last 10 15 20 years the LIGO
experiment last 40 years from beginning
to success and we can talk about what
that means later but but basically in
experimentalist has a certain clock
that's ticking within his or her brain
and that clock is saying what can I
accomplish they'll provide crisp new
evidence that will reveal something new
about the universe that no one's ever
known before so that my student can get
a PhD or postdoc work or I can get a
little you know continue the program of
endeavor that I'm trying to achieve and
sometimes they're very big and sometimes
they're very small but on a daily basis
there's a clock ticking tick tick tick
what did I get done what aspect even if
it's a simple thing and that and that's
where I think we have an advantage
because you know as Richard Fineman once
said you know teaching is good for for
physicists because most of the time
we're not productive coming up with QED
or some new theory of physics so at
least we feel like we accomplished
something when we taught I feel like
that I get to teach and I get to learn
by experimentation every day thinking
about not exactly how to test whether or
not the universe had a singular origin
and in the Big Bang which is a very
important part of my overall mission
that's what I call the big picture
strategic thinking of an experimentalist
what big questions do I want the answer
to do neutrinos have mass what are the
masses of neutrinos is there a CP
violation in the early universe
those are huge quite the tactical day
the day activities that an
experimentalist does or it's probably
very different when the theorist does
and I've written works with theorists a
lot of money I do is is guided by
theorists but on the other hand I can
point to specific tactics every day that
our metrics towards the ultimate
strategic victory that I hope to achieve
and so I think it's a different
perspective it's more practical it's
more it's sort of more it's more
quotidian but on the same token I think
it's just as important as the
theoretical guidance that we get and
furthermore you can produce I feel like
theorists are and I love theories but
you know my father was the theoretical
physicist so I'm gonna say there's no
insult to all you've here but
theoretical physics ons not bozos but
you can create like a lot of them doing
the same kind of cool stuff and but they
won't be able to see if it's right or
wrong until a fermionic experimentalist
comes along and says that doesn't
comport you know and we don't we don't
play nicely right we're not going to
just accept some theory because it's you
in some ways that well ultimately the
experimentalists are the ground of
physics because you can come up with
ideas as much as you want and I think
that one of the reasons why theoretical
physicists get much more play on in the
public's eyes is because I'd like to
know your thoughts I don't know if this
is true but this is what I think is that
they can be expensive and they can be
mystical but the experimentalist job is
to be careful and say no it's yeah
that's right your reticle maybe and
that's more intriguing to the public
because the experimentalist is to be
fastidious and meticulous and exacting
precise as rightly a mathematician needs
to be that same way and you can make an
analogy with your that's not my father
used to say the same thing you say
actually you need to know you need to be
better than the theorists because you
don't have to create new theories but if
you don't understand how the theories
work you're you know in his words you
say you're just like a plumber and I'm
not disparaging plumbers I love plumbers
my cousins apply you know so don't take
this the wrong way but you're just like
doing a technical task you're not
actually doing it for the right reason
which is to understand using the
principle of right reason what is the
importance of this undertaking that
you're that you're pursuing so you know
I always make sure my students my
students spend almost as much time
reading theoretical papers and in fact
as you just said I I will make sure that
they are in you know inundated deluge by
dead theories by theories that didn't
work out because I think that causes
them to acquire the very most difficult
trait which is good taste how do you
know a problem is worth working on if
it's gonna require you know a technology
like I had on James Beecham on Monday
this week is great scientist he's in
particle fever he's helped produce
particle fever he was in chasing
Einstein brilliant physicist he's
arguing for this future circular
Collider in Europe he's an
experimentalist and you know he's saying
like my ultimate dream is like a
particle accelerator at the diameter of
the solar system and I think it's fun to
hear talk like that
because it's it's science fiction and it
goes with my podcast theme at the arthur
c clarke center
but ultimately what I'm concerned with
is I've got you know hopefully 5060
years left I don't know how much you
know I'll be cognizant and be able to
understand it I want to know what I can
accomplish that's practical
that's decisive and that as you said
that I in my book losing the Nobel Prize
I talked about how experimentalists are
kind of like exterminators our job is to
kill off the dog in theories and destroy
theories that don't comport with
evidence we're not required to create
new theories although I've worked to try
to understand maybe phenomenology is the
best way to describe it and and also
look what are the limitations of
experiments don't forget most of my
career I'm looking at noise I'm looking
at thermal radiation which is basically
like noise which can be mimicked is the
most highly entropic form of radiation
that exists how do you distinguish that
disentangle that from other sources of
contamination from the ground which is a
hundred times brighter the Sun which is
a thousand times hotter how do you go
about doing that and so most of our time
is looking for ways to prove ourselves
wrong which is fine and said is the job
to not be to not be fooled I
I think I did myself a great disservice
when I was in the university in in that
I disregarded experimental physics I
despised my it was a second year
requirement for experimental system and
I just it was never explained to me why
you add the error bars and in the way
that you do and I understand now has
something a Taylor expansion but I never
rocked it I didn't understand it yeah
want to spend the time to in and I
regret that because I think that that's
part of my mission is to come up with a
theory of everything or integrate the
other theories of everything or find the
best candidate I see that as a large
area that I'm lacking it would have
significantly helped me yeah you know
what sign says you don't data analysis
right so what scientists and and it's
not you know I don't want to like take
the blame off you entirely because I you
know this is the first time we're
talking but but I do want to say that we
don't teach experimental physics
properly in my opinion we teach it
typically we have a canned packaged
experiment that we know works how do we
know it work because somebody want to
Nobel Prize you know the Davidson Germer
experiment michelson-morley experiment
experiments and then you get this
assumption that everything is is
essentially these night neat little
packages and as I said before well I
spend most of my time looking for is
noise and a lot of experimentalists do
this but there's two different types of
noise there's the statistical noise that
more and more experiments and more and
more observations can reduce to you know
almost negligible values and then
there's a much more important class
called systematic uncertainties and
those are the most challenging because
they require as this a huge theme of the
book and losing the Nobel Prize which I
thought was a unique contribution
because I'm not Brian Greene I'm not
Michiko Kaku I'm not Neil deGrasse Tyson
I'm not a theorist I'm gonna tell you
why is it that certain people lost Nobel
Prizes why did certain people win Nobel
Prizes and it comes down to
understanding the fundamental difference
of being an experimental physicist which
is you're always looking to prove
yourself wrong and furthermore you're
always trying to nail down these
systematic errors and to do some
generalized outside of physics it
probably does you know it probably does
because I think there's bias and there's
systemic features of other features of
the oven of inquiry not just in the
physical sciences but people notice it
every day like I said in my book I
talked about you know if you have dirt
on your windshield you know how do you
know you have dirt well you you you see
a diminution of intensity of light or
whatever I go through an example of that
and what do you do to get to get to see
if to see if you can make a difference
and get rid of it
well you remove by water and then you do
an a/b comparison so you're actually
doing an experiment you're seeing what
was the difference between before and
after and in this case we looked at you
know we were looking at this light now
is it brighter yeah another light sprite
okay so it had a difference if it made
it worse if you wash it with concrete
you know and it wouldn't get better so
so thinking about things in terms of a
systematic error is something that will
require you to do another experiment and
in my case with the bicep experiment and
my colleagues we failed to do a separate
experiment by ourselves we try to do it
in different ways that I described in
the book I won't get into here but we
failed to do an experiment which would
have ruled out the ultimate source of
the signal we claimed were inflationary
gravitational waves which is cosmic dust
in our Milky Way galaxy that required a
separate experiment to get rid of
now we all know that and so now in the
Simon's Observatory pictured behind me
here in the Atacama Desert of Chile and
in the bicep array experiment my
colleagues and running at the South Pole
we now have the capability to measure
not just the Nobel gold winning dust
cold gold winning gravitational wave
signature if it exists which we don't
know but also does simultaneously and
you measure the cosmic signal plus the
dust signal and then you measure the
dust signal by itself you subtracted
from the cosmic close to us and what
you're left with is cosmic estimating
man yeah is that okay so in math and in
physics in theoretical physics
there are seminal books like calculus on
on manifolds that's the fact that's
mathematics then there's whatever
there's some books really good de facto
texts in quantum mechanics for quite a
few of course it's thick you know I I
shouldn't have done this but when I was
younger and I was arrogant and I
ridiculed experimental like like a
theoretical physicist would they view it
I'm sure you know this you must have
boil with hatred but they do it much
like engineering yeah and engineering is
this as I said the plumber you know no
offense the plumbers but yeah that's
that way a lot of theorists view it in
fact one of my friends I won't say his
name because he's a brilliant
he's brilliant physicist and there
aren't too many and and his department
you know he said like okay so what what
you know did you change the valve today
like did you do a carburetor tune-up and
again he didn't you know we were friends
but he come into the lab and I'd be like
well did you write the same paper again
you know about about membranes and
d-brane yeah go ahead he's probably
correct is partly some physical
manipulation but what i envy the most
about your position is understanding the
comprehension from various angles from
that you have to know these theories
inside and out to be able to predict to
making experiments it's no what could be
wrong you have to be passionate I agree
with you curd a hundred percent but you
have to have the passion that that's
curious and that's meaningful to you I
have a lot of students Kurt that are
preternatural II gifted at building
things tinkering things I actually
worked on an old 1970s rabbit Volkswagen
Rabbit
you know when
in high schools my first car it cost me
you know less than my laptop cost me
today
and I love that thing and I loved
working on it and having a sense of
satisfaction every day I could say oh I
tuned up the brakes or I lifted a
suspension I lifted it by a micron or
whatever I was needing back then and and
the point is that you but that was
because I had passion for it some of my
students don't have passion they don't
they don't think about the big picture
questions a lot most of them do some of
them are just really good they can build
in the clean room they can build new
types of detectors they love that pure
technology they are doing engineering
there's truck look behind me in this
picture you see these telescopes and
it's hard to see you know over my
shoulder but there's their diesel
generators I'm students that are like
fascinated with highway diesel
generators work and if they didn't and
they're physicists and they're doing
logistics and what's called project
management it's so crucial Kurt but for
me that's not what really turns me on
about physics it's understanding the
theory that I could understand the way a
four dimensional scalar field would
operate over cosmic time and then say
hmm to measure that not only do I want
to measure that of course any you know
red-blooded physicist with one measure
but I want to understand what are the
impediments to measuring it first that's
what makes so my friend Sabine Haas and
Felder was on my podcast she has this
book lost her tomorrow oh great so she
has her book lost in math you'll talk
about it she'll call her all litany I've
heard it before and I respect her but I
said one of the first things I said in
my interview with her is I said no
experiment is not beautiful like there's
no such thing as even if you look at do
you ever seen a picture curt of the very
first transistor that you know Shockley
Bardeen invented it's like a chip you
know it's like some some silicon or it
looks like a s'more it's got like a coat
hanger and and some and some marshmallow
looks like that that is beautiful
nonetheless because they took materials
that they had and they made it work and
they tested for these contaminations
impurities systemic effects and it is
beautiful also all experiments do what
are called null tests you've probably
heard of these jackknife tests where you
take a set of data look I do the Cosmic
Microwave Background the cosmic
microwave bracken doesn't know that the
data that I'm analyzing was taken on a
Tuesday it doesn't care about that so
therefore if I take data
Tuesday compare it to data on a
Wednesday and subtract it to what should
I get zero zero similarly if I scan back
and forth when I take all the data and I
been it when I was moving the telescope
to the left versus moving it to the
right and I subtract them what should I
get
well that depends them depends on
spatial homogeneity either you know and
it can never pronounce that and then I
saw two people well the but we know that
the cosmic signals themselves are
homogeneous and isotropic so any your D
right there could be deviations from the
ground from the telescope mirrors
whatever I'm just being particularly
yeah so exactly what you're saying it so
their symmetries and the symmetries are
beautiful with Sabine rails against is
the reliance on symmetry to create new
and theories or to have guidance towards
what we're doing in math so I take issue
with the fact that categorically saying
beauty and symmetry and naturalness are
are anathema to new physics so you you
know I would yeah I'm sure you'll hear
that I'm sure you'll get into it but the
basic philosophy that I have is that all
experiments are beautiful
and that her thing is that you should
not be guided by beauty and theory so
maybe we don't agree disagree that much
are there books that our experimentalist
looks much like much like I was
mentioning there's the same cars yeah
quantum mechanics we're super well you
know I I didn't think that there were
and so my book is describes a lot about
how Cosmic Microwave Background
polarimeter works how you measure what
polarization is in the know goes into
losing the Nobel Prize book yes so it's
about how a polarimeter works what is
polarization it's the least well
understood of all the three properties
of light I describe how that works I
describe how you can make your own
polarimeter etc and so I give a lot of
analogies I talk about classic
experiments and I talk about in
particular there was a man named Edward
ohm no relation to the ohm of resistance
Fame but he was working on the exact
same telescope at Bell Labs that Penzias
and Wilson were working on and he did
error analysis incorrectly and because
of that he found that he had this
persistent 3-degree background that he
could not get rid of and he assumed that
that error was due to was due to this
conspiracy of error bars co-editing
together construct
literally doing a mistake that my
freshman in physics would get failure
marks for and and because of that he had
the data that that Penzias and Wilson
would later get four years earlier and
so he is one of the Nobel Prize losers
in the book so I described that what
does that mean to do a systematic error
how how do experimentalist build these
things now there are good there are some
books that talk about it there's a book
by John Mather called the very first
light that describes Coby George Smoot
wrote a book called wrinkles in time
also about Coby and they won the Nobel
Prize in 2006 but you know uh they're in
I was one of the lacunae that I felt I
could repair and make a contribution to
with losing the Nobel Prize how about
for these physicists who are second year
they're smart up reading they're going
into the hopper here and they want to
understand and their theoretical
physicists they want a textbook like
that takes you from from knowing
virtually nothing to how do you yeah
what some experiments and how do you do
this how do you perform the requisite
analysis so Jim Peebles who won the
Nobel Prize last year at Princeton was
hopefully coming on my show pretty soon
and he's written a book called cosmology
century and it goes through he was part
of the original Penzias and Wilson
competitor team at Princeton that lost
the Nobel Prize back in nineteen sixty
and seventy eight when Penzias and
Wilson did win it they were famously
scooped by and this was my graduate
students advisors graduate his advisor
David Wilkinson and team and Peebles
lost the Nobel Prize for the discovery
missed out on discovering the CMB
by only a little bit to this other team
led by Penzias and Wilson anyway Jim
Peebles has written a book called
cosmology century and he goes through a
lot of the classic experiments and how
he came not just to know what we know
about the CMB
which is very important obviously but
also galaxy surveys how did we start
from 1900 knowing almost nothing if the
universe was static eternal infinite
finite whatever to knowing so much about
cosmology the age down to the you know
tens of millions of years the density
down to you know fractions of a percent
the expansion rate depending on who you
talk to to either you know sub percent
or nine percent and etc so it's a
fascinating book it's brand new and
there's another book by a colleague of
mine and Simon's Observatory also at
Princeton named Joe Dunkley she wrote a
book called our universe and then
another Princeton professor let you see
Joe Dunkley Joe and ugly
book called Cosmo our universe and then
Lyman page also at Princeton wrote a
book just out now called The Little Book
of cosmology and they were very
accessible especially to not the first
one Jim Peebles book is more technical
you'll see Einstein equations you'll see
correlation functions but but yeah I
think I think you'll appreciate that
book so has a experimental physicist
what do you think is missing is needed
for robbers to be made on a new theory
of everything or current theories of
everything is it like I was asking you
in the notes isn't it something as
simple as a larger Collider is it to
build the collider in space is it not
even the collider at all is it's just
analyze the cosmic background radiation
with more resolution what is yes so
obviously you know I have a bias towards
two things one things that I can
contribute to because that's where I'm
putting my limited amount of attention
you know you have a little amount of
time but you even have less attention
that you can dedicate right to different
things and so what I feel is worthy of
my attention and that of my you know six
graduate students and six undergraduates
and three postdocs revolves around the
CMB but not only for studying the Cosmic
Microwave Background for looking for
this potential signature of inflation
which would be this twisting curling
pattern of microwaves that were we
claimed also I was part of the bicep2
experiment back in 2014 we declared we
detected it turned out we had to recant
that claim not that we made a blunder or
made a mistake but but we met we
attributed the source of the signal to
an incorrect to an incorrect piece of
evidence the the biggest picture things
to me are to understand whether or not
time
is had a beginning and I think you know
that has just tremendous implications
for for not just me but everybody in
terms of philosophy metaphysics religion
if you believe small and has a great
book on that if you read it yeah yeah so
I'm in I'm in the middle of it I was
invited to a conference at perimeter
Institute near you three or four years
ago where I started to have
conversations about him that could use
the CMB to determine if there is a clock
a certain Universal clock and that
Universal clock might be connected to
what we talked about in terms of CPT
violation CP violation and that's using
the properties of polarization as a sort
of detector of mirror symmetry so we
know that something called CPT violation
is respected but we and we know that CP
violation takes place but the kind of
interface between the two of them can
best be tested across cosmic scales
because if there's a we know that
whatever effect there is that breaks
symmetry in the electromagnetism world
and the sector that we call photons
there has to be incredibly small but
over cosmic distances of billions of
light years of travel time you might see
the evidence for the rotation of
polarization of both photons and some
say even of gravitational waves so
there's a huge area of physics that's
left to be explored and that I believe
will tell us a lot about the fundamental
aspects of the of electromagnetism and
then if you do believe that the is a
grand unified theory plus gravity so a
theory of everything then you would have
to argue that if if the weak force
disobeys parity symmetry then gravity
must at very high energies and so
where's the best place to look for
gravity's behavior at very high energies
the Big Bang or a bounce and that's
something proposed by my colleague Paul
Steinhardt at Princeton that the
universe is actually cyclical that there
was no Big Bang that there is no single
origin of time that the universe
undergoes but perfectly classical
physics bounces and expansions over
trillions of years not just you know
billions of years
and and this is also related there's
really related work by Roger Penrose and
you may know this conformal cyclical
cosmology so that's the biggest question
you could possibly answer is time unique
is it did it have a beginning is it a
singular origin as you know as people
claim or are there other you know
aspects of of the universe that we can
only study using the universe as our
biggest possible accessible particle
accelerator do you think their imprint
in principle limitations to experimental
physics for example lee smolin said that
you can't make theories about the
universe from within the universe they
believe that's in time were born I don't
know if you understand yeah
really no yeah so I've heard him speak
about that and I think that's related to
this book which I don't want to break
their conversation enough to go look up
this book but he has his doubts about
the existence even of the scientific
method so if the scientific method which
relies on hypothesis kind of you know
some kind of conjecture some some crisp
test some ability to be proven wrong in
the case of popper etc then yeah you
might you might think that if that isn't
maintained in other words if you don't
believe that that's the cinah qua non of
physics of science itself then you know
then trying to rely on experiment to
reveal something new is plagued and
fraught with the very bias that you're
trying to sell up systole
you know eliminate which is that you can
learn something about the universe from
within the universe and and you know I
think it's a fascinating question and
Lee is one of the most original thinkers
I know so it's not possible for me to
ignore what he says on a day-to-day
basis do I think that it's not possible
to to learn about the universe not no I
do I believe we can learn tremendously
about the about the about the
composition the structure of the
universe on a practical level and so to
be honest I don't really concern myself
so much of like these questions the
ultimate question like do I exist you
know do I have free will
I actually don't personally find those
interesting I know you're interested in
it yeah
you forget about if you find it
interesting do you happen to believe
that you have free well I do yeah in
general I do and how does that comport
with your experiment to its reductionism
I don't know if you believe in
reductionism I don't I don't necessarily
believe in reductionism I find all these
things kind of again so I participated
with Stewart Hoffman who is a good
friend not Stuart Hoffman Stuart
Hameroff at University of Arizona who
runs a science of consciousness seminar
every other year alongside Roger Penrose
and others and actually Noam Chomsky
spoke with me a few years ago here in
San Diego when I was here and you know I
became very frustrated and disillusioned
a little bit because they couldn't even
like say for sure what consciousness was
and yet they said they have a science of
consciousness or they're working towards
a science of condign oh sam harris is
the hard problem until you understand so
it's not so much that I feel if I can
prove it or I feel like I'm a hypocrite
because I believe in free will even
though I am an experiment no it's more
that I think the burden is on other
people who believe that there isn't free
will and there isn't you know there
there is super determinism and I know
people will just throw it around like
the block universe and it's just but
there's no evidence for it so I guess
the question is will give you yeah go
ahead
sure let's say you have free will
okay well so that means you made a
decision of your own choosing well what
caused you to choose in that particular
direction and then if you say well I had
some play in that well then I ask what
cost that it's just what cause until you
get to something guys outside of you so
for example the initial conditions of
the Big Bang maybe or your mother giving
birth to you which you didn't choose how
is it that you have free will I guess I
would ask kind of like the Turing quite
like how would you tell the difference
like if I did have free will you know
you know as they say like I have to
believe in free will I have no choice
but but the question of you know I would
say isn't that is that the super you
know the super set of all events that
have taken place since the Big Bang if
you want to say that that's
deterministic when we know that there's
certain quantum decoherence effects that
cannot be
modeled as intrinsically being
deterministic or could possibly allow
for for violations of certain bells
inequalities if you look at it that way
I guess it's just then then it becomes
very very too much too all-encompassing
so like I recount to somebody a couple
days ago like when I was dating my wife
we went to an astrologer and she knew I
didn't believe in astrology and she
wanted to have fun so she said go tell
her tell her about yourself and she'll
predict your horoscope and so I said
yeah I'm Pisces I do this this and this
you know it's gonna be good you guys are
gonna do this and and and I said is it
is it really true that Pisces are born
in September I forgot oh no you're born
in September well you're a Virgo
but don't worry this everything I said
is still gonna happen so it's like what
was the what is the difference like if
everything is not so all-encompassing
then I guess then we're - by the way oh
you are okay well virgos are the ones in
their right minds or so that I don't
know I think you know as anything I
think you're right I think you're right
well well I also happen I wouldn't say I
believe in free will but I don't find
the arguments against free well as
particularly convincing I just wants to
know what your opinion is so is it your
counter argument is that is the Turing
test how would you tell one way or the
other to this question exactly and and
and isn't it I'm I'm a pragmatist Kurt
you know at the end of the day you know
what I'm concerned about are things that
I can get a crisp answer to so I don't
believe I'll ever get a crisp answer to
that nor do i and you could ask me about
God and I don't think our gonna have
like some answer about God or the
existence of God but I think you know I
think a place for a physicist especially
an experimentalist is to be agnostic but
actually agnostic which means like if
you just don't go to church or you don't
go to synagogue in my case you go to the
same you know you have the same
religious performance as as Richard
Dawkins like there's no functional
delineation between you and Richard
Dawkins actually had this conversation
with Freeman Dyson before he passed away
you know cuz he said he's an agnostic
and I said well what church do you go to
because I don't really go to church I
said - oh so you go to the same church
as Richard Dawkins and he's like
cognitive dissonance a little bit so
what I look at is behaviorism so how do
I behave and if I knew that
was controlled by you know the initial
conditions state if there was a big bang
which we don't so I guess I think about
it in terms of what is the pragmatic
day-to-day implication of this does it
it doesn't have any bearing on me
individually so in the case of free will
I don't think it does I don't think I'll
behave differently and treat my kids you
know make one kid hits another one I
said oh you didn't really have free will
so I'm not gonna be now of course I'm
gonna punish them or make them
understand and apologize I'm not gonna
lay it off as some people like Michael
Shermer or I've had this conversation
you know he basically is much more
libertine about this on the other hand
if God exists that's a much bigger
question right as and I'm not saying I'm
not I'm not saying if I believe or I
don't
as I said I'm a fully practicing devout
agnostic meaning I go to services I read
and I learn I've taught myself Aramaic
so I could understand the arguments of
the second holiest book in judaism
called the talmud I learned that age
thirty it wasn't easy and I study it on
a regular basis because I want to take
it seriously because if God exists that
would have a if you knew for I don't
know your religious beliefs and it
almost doesn't matter to me
but if you knew like I asked Sean
Carroll this question I said you once
you know what is the probability the
multiverse is true said 50% when I said
what's the probability that God exists
he said less than less than five right
right he didn't say zero so imagine now
that means he's open he is a brilliant
man so I could tell him I could let's
say I provide evidence whatever some
miracle that he can't dismiss and then
he believes it so he would change his
life I know that he would even though I
know I don't think he thinks the
probability is even that high by the way
but but it was a good soundbite we had a
good conversation about it but do you
know what I'm saying a Kurt the bottom
line is I am concerned with things that
will impact my life as a behaviorist how
will it change my behavior how will I
change my treatment of the poor the sick
my wife my kids you how will I change my
behavior is much more influenced to the
good I would say by wrestling with the
question of whether or not God exists
whether or not it does exist is an
important question for that reason
because if the answer is yes it would
have huge implications and even Dawkins
has said
he doesn't rule it out so so but free
will if you told me that you know
everything is super deterministic it
wouldn't change how I operate on a daily
basis you mentioned you mentioned if the
Big Bang happened no you also said
earlier that we have evidence and I
think it was Jim people's book that goes
over how you how we even know about what
an instantaneous amount of time after
the infinitesimal amount of time a Big
Bang
okay well but that's after the Big Bang
that's free suppose in the Big Bang so
not necessarily do yeah so I already say
if I could ask God if God exists you
know what what happened one question I
say what happened on the Tuesday before
the Big Bang in other words you know
Hawking needs to say it doesn't make
sense to ask what predated the Big Bang
right I don't think that's actually
correct because you can have many many
legitimate scenarios in which time is
cyclical it's just that there's
possibility for that and and if that
happens there's a perfectly great
explanation for what happened on the
Tuesday before the Big Bang it was a
firey hellscape of collapsing you know
all the material energy and and
properties of the early of the universe
that pre-existed are again I'm not
sustaining I believe I'm just saying it
is a well posed question now can a
theorist and an experimentalist work
together as Paul Steinhardt and and his
collaborators are working and in part
the mission of the Simons Observatory is
to falsify his hypothesis so you cannot
falsified the Big Bang hypothesis as
such in other words the Big Bang would
be an aspect of a collapsing universe
scenario called the cyclic universe
there'd be the equivalent of a hot dense
and I get another you know shout out to
Sean Carroll he says a good thing which
is that the big when you say the Big
Bang you're really talking about a
period about a minute or two from the
from time backwards to a minute before
this event when our extrapolations of
classical physics would imply a
singularity it's basically the end of
our of our knowledge or the beginning of
our ignorance he calls it so the Big
Bang is really a Shibboleth it's a
shortcut
it's a code word for where does our
ignorance
stop and our ignorance stops about a
minute afterwards when we start making
we start synthesizing the very first
elements you know I'm good I happen to
think that our ignorance is so far
greater and I did this thought
experiment where it's like imagine a few
billion years from now and maybe it may
be 90 billion or whatever whatever order
of magnitude and then and we're on earth
and we have our Sun but we look out and
we and the galaxies are moving so far
away that we can see almost nothing but
we wouldn't we wouldn't know that
anything else existed that's right ok so
that's just a few billion years from now
given presuming our current theories of
general relativity cosmological
expansion are correct ok well what about
now why do we think that we're in such a
privileged position that we have so much
knowledge to even think we're on the
were 1% of the way there to a theory of
everything for example by the way what
do you think of Erik Weinstein's theory
of everything so he and I are very close
collaborators friends and and we talk
about this a lot I've encouraged him to
to really start thinking about ways that
we could revive both the both the kind
of excitement and the sociological
milieu that happened before 1974 in
physics and that's the period of time
that Sabine and Erik and others have
claimed that was like basically the end
of physics like they're having the new
discoveries or predictions which I argue
with and both of them on my podcast but
but it's but essentially they want he
wants to recreate the urgency of the
Manhattan Project of the MIT radar
laboratory of the world war two
generation of the Shelter Island
generation post-world War two when
physicists were chauffeured around by
Secret Service agents because they
contain within them
national secrets and national treasures
he wants to recreate that and and I'm
hoping to you know engage with him as an
experimentalist I'm not a mathematician
I do understand some of the math that
goes into it
you must know that he is you know
universally looked upon in the physics
community with Bose with both skepticism
because he hasn't published anything
although enjoy my if you go to my
my YouTube interviews with him I've done
two now and in the second one I have
actually downloaded his slides from his
Oxford talk in 2013 one of my
undergraduates digitized them and so if
you sign up for my mailing list at Bryan
Keating com I'll send you a copy of his
lecture notes from that lecture in 2013
that's about as close as we get right
now because he's in that making hay
phase skirt which I'm sure you've been
in the state of flow where you're
actually incur just producing great
content for your film for your for your
research for the other projects for this
YouTube channel and you're just
singularly focused on this thing and
obsesses you and you want to learn more
about it before you then take these
tentative furtive steps to publication
so I would say I said he's looked upon
but simultaneously with skepticism but
also dismay because he's a great
communicator of science and he believes
as he said in my podcast interview that
physicists are the worst at PR that have
ever existed because we have the
greatest material and instead we just
keep regurgitating the same double-slit
experiment
wormholes multi ver you know when we
have the hopf fibration I'm not saying
if I 100% agree with Eric Weinstein all
night it's incredibly incredibly boring
yeah oh yeah it can be up and down at
the same time exactly so there's a limit
to that so I but but then he'll go on
just Rogan and soon referring to
superposition to them yeah and he'll go
on Joe Rogan show and six million people
will watch it and you know that's six
million people that will be potentially
there's some kid out there who would
like me at age 12 didn't that podcast
back then but but well think well that's
really cool I want to learn about psy
used to read Isaac Asimov not as science
fiction books he wrote a tremendous
amount of nonfiction in science
chemistry the history of chemistry I
devoured it at age 12
flatland the book flatland have you ever
read that book hurt no oh you got rid of
her too many will love it Carlsen it has
it's it's by Edward Abbey in the late
1800s Victorian England and it's
actually like a commentary on racism
which is really fascinating but but it
also talks about what it's like for a to
creature to visualize the third
dimensions and in so doing it helps you
visualize what the fourth dimension
might look like to a three-dimensional
creature you have to read that so that
was an internal bookkeeping about boats
earlier but that is one of them because
I started thinking geometrically and
there's always the siren song of
thinking geometrically that leads you to
beauty and symmetry and everything else
but in my case it actually led me to
like well let me think about things that
I can't access with experiments so the
most important experiments are called
Gedanken experiments thought experiments
Einstein was the greatest
experimentalist of all time in that
sense because that's what led him to
create theories of relativity and both
both theory general and special so I
hope that kids out there will take what
Eric's doing and seriously I am trying
to encourage him to actually I've
actually invited him on record multiple
times on the only physicist in the world
apparently which is sad to me that's
invited him to be a scholar and
residents here in San Diego and and work
on an actual experimental predictions
and tests for geometric unity which is
what he calls this theory of everything
I've also had on Stephen Wolfram on my
podcast I've also encouraged him to look
for you know ways that we can
collaborate together to think of ways we
could test it as an experimentalist
because again I am obsessed with time
tick tock tick tock and I'm obsessed
with the brevity of life and how short a
period of attention span we have to make
discoveries and so I don't waste my time
but if there are potential avenues like
Eric could be correct could be wrong
Paul Steinhardt could be correct could
be wrong with regard to the bouncing
models that he's proposed Stephen
Wolfram could be right could be wrong so
I'm actually talking later today about
ways we can get the whole physics
community together and a kind of like a
shelter island or revival of the theory
of everything studies maybe through
Scott zoom maybe through a webinar
something like that and thinking really
big to attract the greatest minds to
attack this problem and rejuvenate as
eric says this rock star status that
physicists used to have in the in the
20th century okay it's there much
movement on that this Manhattan physics
project or is it right now it's just
conversation between you and Eric and me
to other people and it's a yeah I'm sort
of an inspired by in part by by David
Kaiser my friend at MIT who wrote a book
recently called quantum legacies about
the the aftershocks of the world war two
projects and when physicists were
chauffeured around with you know
bodyguards and and also by Erik so no
we're thinking about it we we have
picked around some ideas for an hour to
yesterday I'll let you know when if we
can actually put together that would be
the dream like the Solvay conference you
ever seen that picture with like Marie
Curie and Niels Bohr and I said you know
I would I be taking the picture and
putting it on Instagram I wouldn't be
actually in the picture but the point is
let's get let's get the most creative
people together but we can't ignore
funding we cannot ignore basic research
funding and that's what's so exciting
about partnering with the Simons
Foundation they really primarily support
non application driven science mainly
math computer science computational
biology astrophysics and now the Simon's
Observatory pictured behind me to look
at potential resolutions and answers to
you know the greatest questions of the
human mind single audience where they
can find out more about you and what
you're up to
so I'm doing a lot you asked me in the
notes we didn't you know fully or in the
beginning my mission is really to
communicate you know what I want to be
and maybe I injured spirit with you it's
kind of like the Joe Rogan of science
like I want to do stuff and it doesn't
have to be restricted to science they're
people like we mentioned Dave Rubin zu
B's is gonna appear soon Michael Shermer
they're not scientists per se but but
basically they're of an affinity either
for science fiction which I claim allows
you to do thought experiments and so we
talk about things that revolve around
academic freedom in the case of my
podcast which you can find on YouTube at
dr. Bryan Keating Dr Bryan Keating and
you can find me on Twitter and my goal
is to really have incredible
conversations that stimulate me to think
about the future legacy that I want to
leave on earth which is which is to have
this impact on cleaning wisdom and
communicating a vision for
curiosity for wonder for imagination and
and that's part of you know this
tripartite vision that I have for my
life so yes
long story short find my podcast I'm dr.
Bryan Keating on YouTube hopefully you
can link to it and link back and and
then I'm on Twitter dr. Bryan Keating
Instagram same thing and I have a
mailing list where I send out things
like personal notes and book
recommendations from people like Jim
Simon's to Eric Weinstein etc